lift off first thing in the morning next
to your rocket launcher alarm clock and
watch as it flies majestically alongside
this remote-control Eagle because it's
episode 51 of loot hook-up your optical
device with your smartphone using the
hook ups universal adapter that allows
you to record and share everything you
see with your monoculars binoculars
telescopes microscopes night vision or
spotting scopes spot liars after hooking
them up to the digital USB polygraph a
lie detector test that uses digital
sensors to measure skin response and
pulse the same data used in real light
Tector sets set your Salvador Dali watch
to half past mustache and if you
mustache how dinosaurs loved their dogs
there's a book for that if you want to
fix busted cables there's a plastic
welder for that bondic is the world's
first liquid plastic welder it's not a
glue it won't dry out and can be used on
metal plastic fabric and even would you
like a loan sculpture like dragon and
chimp and bat on a branch mermaid
octopus nothing rhymes with branch
gopher
gofer branch out from just eating ice
cream and make your own in the ice cream
ball simply add ice and rock salt in one
end and ice cream mix in the other and
roll it around for 20 minutes caution do
not kick or throw this carabiner
grappling hook to help guide falling
trees or help you climb stuff then put
your stuff down on a foosball coffee
table which allows you to finally play
foosball in front of your couch swap out
your old couch for some ridiculously
fancy seats from elite home theater
seating they allow you to fully
customize everything from the armrest
and backrest to whether you prefer the
material to be made out of red silk
leather or grapes in a suede which
sounds great but if you really love
yourself you'll give yourself hickeys a
no tie shoelace replacement lacing
system which features a responsive
design that moves with your feet so you
can stop bothering with tying your shoes
and spend some quality time with your
bag of mangled mimes I hope you don't
mind morbidity because here are some
skeleton playing cards that showcase 54
skeletons found at the Museum of
osteology including everything from the
harpy eagle to the pac-man frog who's
clearly hopped his last hop home your
hops using the sonic our portable beer
foam head generator simply turn on the
device touch it to a glass of beer and
watch ultrasonic waves create a foam
head rock your boss in the head after
completely customizing your own
whack-a-mole game video amusement offers
total graphic customization from the
backlit panels and cabinet side art to
the mole heads themselves just in case
you've ever wanted to whack a manhole
fill the hovercraft sized hole in your
heart by dropping a hundred and ninety
thousand dollars on the flying
hovercraft
then don't be perplexed about what to do
next the Perplexus Wharf is a spherical
octahedron maze that's sure to keep you
busy conquering it's 80 challenging
events so stay optimistic because
technically the glass is always full and
as always thanks for watching
you